Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this is my
Agents Of SHIELD episode 5 video.
Lots of awesome stuff like Mockingbird from
the comics, a big WTF with Skye’s Dad.
And Marvel dropped a pretty huge bomb.
Next week they’ll be posting the first official
Avengers 2 Trailer during the agents of shield
episode.
I already did a breakdown of the comic con
trailer they showed off.
But the trailer they’ll post next week will
be all new footage.
That’s going to be the first video I post
that night.
So be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll talk more about the footage I think
we’ll see after I we get through SHIELD
craziness.
Careful for spoilers in case you haven’t
seen the episode.
Starting with Top 5 Moments,
Number 5 - HYDRA is trying to weaponize the
Obelisk
That group in the beginning they were testing
it on were people with Ties to SHIELD.
They weren’t all SHIELD agents, but HYDRA
was using them as a test.
They used cells from the woman in the cafe
to try and reverse engineer the effects.
There aren’t that many people that have
touched the obelisk, so when Kraken was talking
about Tissue cells he was talking about her.
Before shit went down, Simmons was probably
going to start working on Obelisk research.
There was actually a big Hell Cow Howard the
Duck easter egg when she was in the lab.
They were talking about milk from a hell cow.
It’s a character named Bessie that appeared
in Giant Sized Man Thing Issue 5.
The story goes that she was a regular cow.
Dracula drank her blood, she died, her farmer
buried her and 3 days later she rose as a
vampire cow.
So she’s a cow with humanoid vampire qualities.
She had a crossover with Howard the Duck.
So that’s what the Bessie Hellcow Milk stuff
was about.
Number 4 - Raina Is In Trouble
I feel kind of bad for her character.
It’s the classic situation where the evil
temptress becomes sympathetic because she
gets mistreated by the villains she serves.
It’s like Mystique turning against Magneto.
It just seems like they’re setting up Raina
as a double agent inside HYDRA.
She wants evolution and as we saw at the end.
Kraken and Skye’s Father only care about
themselves.
Tiny Violins of course, she is a verified
scumbag.
So of course she’s going to burn Team Coulson
in the end.
She really is the Mystique of the series.
Regardless of what battle lines are drawn.
She’s just going to skip around the chess
board and escape at the end.
We did get a little teaser for her backstory.
Skye’s father did something to her.
It sounds like it was way more than just give
her a place to live and food to eat.
Like he helped her attain some skills.
She seems like she has low level passive mutant
abilities and she’s trying to unlock her
true potential.
Which just screams Inhumans to me.
The Obelisk is an alien device, so it could
be what Marvel is using to represent Terrigen
Crystals.
If that’s the case, the map could be a map
to Attilan.
Number 3 - Coulson Comes Clean About the Alien
Markings
Based on the way he talked about the carvings
just coming out without him actively thinking
about them.
The carving is an unconscious thing, he doesn’t
think about what the map is supposed to look
like.
I’m thinking 2 possibilities Inhumans or
Guardians of The Galaxy.
I’ll explain Inhumans first.
The whole idea behind terragenesis is that
it unlocks something inside you that is hidden.
Or just strips away the shell.
So if Coulson’s subconscious is forcibly
working it’s way to the surface it could
be an early stage of what happens when you
take in the terrigen mists.
Not everyone survives them, sometimes the
mists kill people.
The ones that survive become inhumans and
get crazy powers.
It’s like a way of saying there is a brave
new world coming, not everyone is meant to
live in it.
Like Garrett.
Coulson said he thought Garrett wasn’t meant
to survive the Kree formula.
Marvel is pretty convoluted when it comes
to who has the rights to what characters.
I think they have the rights to Inhumans,
so they could do them if they wanted.
If that’s what’s going on, the map could
be a map to Attilan, the city of the inhumans
or it could be a genetic map.
The other possibility with the carvings is
that it’s a literal map to something from
the Guardians of The Galaxy stories.
Like outer space map.
And Marvel is using Agents of SHIELD to link
those things to their earth based Marvel stories.
I think this is less likely, just because
James Gunn said Guardians 2 wasn’t adding
any new human characters and he just wanted
it to be off in it’s own corner of the Marvel
Universe.
Meaning that Guardians stuff would not directly
overlap with the other Marvel Movie stuff.
So I’m 99 percent positive they’re not
going to do marvel in space.
But regardless, I do think the Obelisk or
the Diviner is Kree in origin.
Number 2 - Shit Goes Down at HYDRA
The standoff between Raina and Coulson was
actually pretty funny.
Coulson just not buying her shit.
We knew that Mockingbird was going to be a
double agent, the promos pretty much explained
it last week.
But seeing her go all Black Widow was awesome.
Simmons is always pretty hilarious in situations
like that.
Which I think made it work better.
I don’t like SHIELD as much when it takes
itself too seriously.
It’s a lot more fun to play the Simmons
lols off the crazy Bashki villain.
It’s like a cross between Borne Trilogy
parkour and Avengers Humor.
In real life, the actors were sitting right
next to each other live-tweeting the episode.
I always laugh a little when you see villains
and heroes on shows just chilling out like
bros in real life.
The rooftop stunt was really cool too with
the quintjet reveal.
They keep giving simmons crazier and crazier
stunts, so I’m interested to see if she
and Fitz get a big action moment like this
now that they’ve been reunited.
That was big, them being in the same room
together but it ended up feeling like a downer.
I’m sure they’ll slowly get back to fitzsimmons
by the middle of the season.
and my Number 1 Moment - Mockingbird joins
the Team
I feel like back when they announced she was
going to be on the episode and Hunter went
on and on about his ex-wife we all wondered
if it might be Mockingbird.
It just seemed like it would be too sweet.
I was so happy when they confirmed it, it
just means the team will get to have that
much more fun giving Hunter, admittedly a
douche bag, a bunch of shit about it.
Based on her rapport with the team, she goes
way back with most of the older members of
the team.
The reference to her hair was just a nod to
Mockingbird in the comics being Blonde.
Also adrianne palicki was blonde on Friday
Night Lights.
So you could either take it as a wink to the
comics or to that.
Palicki did an interview recently where she
said there was potential for her character
to cross over into the movies.
It’s too late for her to show up in Avengers
2, they’ve already finished the film.
But she’ll probably cameo in one of the
phase 3 movies.
Captain America 3 would be the most likely
since those are always feature a lot of SHIELD
characters.
Just as a bonus I wanted to talk about Skye’s
Dad, he didn’t really fit into any of my
other moments, but he’s a huge character.
Very clearly affected by the Obelisk.
I’m guessing he studied it for a long time
and was changed.
We didn’t see him transform or anything
but it did seem like he had super strength.
Skye called him a monster, so don’t be surprised
if he physically turns into a monster by the
end of his arc.
I’m hoping he makes it past the mid-season
finale.
The Garrett character made it through a whole
season.
So right now I’m thinking of him as the
new Garrett.
Kraken is the big bad, but think about HYDRA
this year being a version of masters of evil.
With a couple top tier villains.